in the Year 1960 I discovered a
wonderful almost immoral animal that
possessed characteristics soon to
astound even the most worded scientists
although it sounds like science fiction
these animals live for years perhaps
centuries in suspended animation sealed
in magic crystals time travelers
journeying through the fourth dimension
when you witness the miracle of instant
life a door will open that had always
been close to you a door to a new
dimension in your awareness of the
nature of life
only a dollar plus 25 cents shipping
[Music]
at the end of World War two Americans
were having lots of kids and if kids
love anything its toys and if they love
anything else
it's pets and also kids love surprises
this is the story of a man named Harold
von Braun high who once had an idea for
all those new American kids an idea that
combines pets toys and surprises it was
a small idea that would have a big
impact on generations to come Harold's
idea came from the strangest place a
bucket of brine shrimp cottony sold his
fish food he looked into the bucket and
said to himself I think I can make the
best foods into the pet harold von braun
hood set out to sell brine shrimp to
kids as pets
you see Harold realized that brine
shrimp might look boring but they
actually have this cool superpower
called cryptobiosis to survive long
periods of drought brine shrimp produce
eggs that can remain dormant for years
or even decades to the naked human eye
the eggs just look like tiny grains of
sand but if you just add water
I thought if you could see it come to
life I mean what would be more
remarkable than that the world's only
instant live pets this is how Harold
made it work first you pour ordinary tap
water into the microview ocean zoo
microview ocean zoo then you put in the
contents of packet number 1 the water
purifier pocket number 1 purifies the
water you must wait 24 hours for the
purification process to complete by the
way for a kid this is like a super long
time packet number 2 is where the magic
happens you drop these mysterious
crystals into the tank and your new pets
just instantly appear kids were gonna
love it but he still needed a name and
although it would prove a confusing
choice too literally everybody else in
the world
- harold von braun hut it was obvious
sea-monkeys in a clever move harold
skipped over parents and marketed
directly to the kids everyone else was
buying TV time so I went to comic books
back then a lot of companies look down
on comic books I bought something like
3.2 million pages of comic book
advertising a year hey it worked
beautifully
hired Joe Orlando later vice president
of DC Comics to draw the advertisements
those Joe Orlando images are iconic
beyond belief but the ad copy that was
all heralds and heralds really had a
voice bubbling over with spectacular
tricks these tiny talented troopers
perform like will psychist us what's the
comic antics of these fantastic
underwater balloons that are actually
really alive order now only a dollar
plus 25 cents shipping
[Music]
[Music]
x-ray glasses spy pens see mugeez and a
real rocket ship fully two bucks oh it's
all novelty boat trick little kids none
of that crap ever worked this might be a
good time to acknowledge that for a lot
of people sea monkeys are kind of just a
scam like maybe their most famous for
being a massive disappointment not for
everyone mind you but still for a lot of
kids sea monkeys marked a key moment in
childhood where you learn that real life
is just not as awesome as your dreams
sometimes real life is just downright
crappy but what are you loved sea
monkeys or hate them man I love sea
monkeys you have to admit it's pretty
amazing that Harald could breathe this
much magic into brine shrimp and it's
not just that harold has sold sea
monkeys to tens of millions of kids over
decades sea monkeys have also warranted
serious study like at this place the
center for post natural history we're a
small museum that is dedicated to living
organisms that have been intentionally
altered by people through selective
breeding domestication or genetic
engineering we view these organisms as
works of culture we're specifically
interested in sea monkeys because to the
best of our knowledge they're the only
living creature that's ever been
specifically bred so that its lifecycle
would match the life cycle of a toy most
people when they think of sea monkeys
they think about advertisements that
look like these and they would promise
that if you sent away your dollar and
your coupon you would get back at these
little anthropomorphic people in reality
what you get are these tiny little
monster creatures that are wiggling
around and you can barely see them
Harald once said that he was inspired by
the flea circuses he'd seen as a child
that people would willingly believe and
talented fleas that obviously didn't
exist girl invented all of these
different add-ons one of them was called
Cupid's arrow it was sort of a sea
monkey viagra and things like the banana
treat that if you look closely at it it
looks an awful lot like they're smoking
banana peels does anyone get that
reference anymore banana peels very
little is known about Harold von Braun
Hut but what we do know is pretty
amazing he raced motorcycles as the
Green Hornet's he managed the careers of
entertainers novelty acts like the great
gun insurer and Henry lamothe who had
died from 60 feet into just 12 inches of
water
Harold was the antithesis of the
post-war calm
he took a black-and-white world and put
it in color and he didn't just invent
sea-monkeys Harold was a prolific
inventor his inventions included x-ray
specs sea-doo goes crazy air breathing
crabs as gentle as a pussycat and
amazing hair-raising monsters just add
water and start this crazy horse show
right in your own home his best
invention though was the invisible
goldfish all you had to do was send in
your dollar and you'd get an empty fish
tank and some fish food the ad copy
promised you would never see the
goldfish by the late 1960s Harold had a
problem his sea monkeys were selling
well and they did work they just didn't
work very well only one or two would
survived per batch and they had a
limited shelf life so Harold teamed up
with an actual brine shrimp expert named
dr. Anthony D'Agostino and the two of
them said about breeding a hybrid brine
shrimp so they could live in its dormant
egg state for as long as possible
grow as big as possible and live as long
as possible
Harold was in one sense operating as a
kind of 20th century
PT Barnum but at the same time the
invention and experimentation that went
into making sea monkeys work was a lot
more like a Thomas Edison United States
patent number three million six hundred
seventy three thousand nine hundred
eighty six five July fourth nineteen
seventy two methods and materials used
for hatching brine shrimp a closer read
of Harold seamonkey patent reveals that
he's been fooling us all along but not
in the way you might think remember I
showed you how to make Seema
well it turns out this process is more
like a magic trick than a science
experiment packet number one is supposed
to be the water purifier this purifies
the water what Harold doesn't tell you
is that packet number one also contains
the eggs now you must wait 24 hours for
the purification process to complete so
when he tells you to wait 24 hours
before adding packet number two it's a
form of misdirection what he's really
doing is giving the sea-monkeys time to
get big enough where you can actually
see them so during that whole day you
are anxiously waiting to put in packet
number two and create instant life the
sea monkeys are already alive they've
been hiding in plain sight you must wait
24 hours so what is in packet number two
blue dye Harold put a tiny bit of blue
dye in packet number two this dye
settles on the now day old sea monkeys
and makes them even easier to see so
instant life is real cryptobiosis
remember but Harold knew it just didn't
look that cool so he created this whole
elaborate stage show in illusion of
instant life that's just a little better
than the real thing
[Music]
this is where things get a bit strange
and a lot darker in 1968 Harold Patton
did something called the chi yoga spring
whip chi yoga the steel Cobra is an
automatically magnetically triggered
steel whip on with a heavy caliber
striking tip nobody needs to know you
are secretly armed to the teeth the
advertisements that he took out for the
Kyoto spring whip are eerily similar to
the ones that he took out for sea
monkeys same layout same coupons and
perhaps most troubling the same address
then in an even stranger turn harold
pledged the profits of the Cayuga to the
Aryan Nations according to the
anti-defamation league which kept a
large file on him Harold was a very
generous and very active member of this
group and then there is someone named
Hendrik von Braun
[Music]
an overwhelming amount of evidence
forces me to conclude that the man you
are looking at here is actually Harold
[Music]
[Music]
one person who knew Harold quoted him as
saying Hitler wasn't a bad guy he just
got bad press it's the great mystery
lurking out behind the SeaMonkey castle
how does the guy own events all of these
wonderfully playful fun things also
promote such horrible ideas the closer I
look the more different these two
Harold's appear to be to me now I have
to back up and tell you that Harold had
yet another identity and yet another
name Harold von Braun hutt was born
Harold Brown Hut to a Jewish family in
New York so now we have the inventor of
sea-monkeys
who is Jewish pledging large portions of
his fortune to an anti-semitic hate
group those reports are all lies I don't
have to defend myself to you or anyone
else the calm down here
[Music]
Harold files his final patent in 2002
background of the invention kids love
pets for some children pet service
friends confidence items of affection
and a grams of consolation for other
children pets take the place of brothers
and sisters they never had or will have
one drawback of aquatic pets however is
that they must be kept in a stationary
tank at home oftentimes children are
left to fixate on their watch counting
down the hours minutes and finally
seconds until they can get back to
playtime with their beloved sea monkeys
there is a need for a means to allow sea
monkeys to be enjoyed around the clock
so to speak such need is met by the
aquarium watch of the present invention
when I look at sea monkeys what I see is
the imprint of Harold's imagination
harold von braun hut was one part genius
inventor to one part flim-flam man and
add another part so dark it casts a
shadow over his whole legacy people are
complicated life is complicated life can
be disappointing and heartbreaking and
life can be magical and fun and it's all
right there in the tiny story of Harold
and his amazing live sea monkeys
[Music]
you
[Music]